When we're in a relationship,
one of the haunting thoughts that can
make us especially snappy and bitter
is the idea that if only we were single,
we would be a lot happier.
We can be so conscious of
the troubles of our current lives,
we are naturally drawn to look back
and remember the nicer aspects of solitude.
We remember being able to
get up whenever we wanted;
we recall not having to fret
about where we threw things.
We remember how inoffensive
our own bad habits were,
when we were the only ones to witness them.
We recall not having to justify
our meal choices, however eccentric;
we could go out somewhere
and never tell anyone;
we could (when we felt like it)
work through till 2 a.m. without
being accused of being obsessive or cold.
Though we were sometimes sad,
we could always hope for a better future.
It was also fulfilling, in comparison with
the life we lead now.
But memory is a hugely unreliable
and therefore, reckless instrument,
which isn’t a small point,
for our power of record has a huge impact
on how we assess our lives in the present.
We are editors of genius,
who know just enough about
how to romanticise our single days
in order to poison our conjugal ones.
Some of our ingratitude might be eroded.
If long before we met anyone,
a talented film-maker were charged with
making a close observational documentary
about our lives as single people.
They’d capture our face at 5.30pm
on a winter Sunday afternoon,
as the sun is setting
and we know we’ll be alone till
we reach the office on Monday morning.
They’d observe us looking across the room
at someone at a party
longing for their kindly face
but lacking any courage to
go up and address them.
They’d capture us spending
a lot of time at our parents’ house,
and growing increasingly
tetchy in their company.
They’d show us struggling to know what
to do when the fridge stopped working
or we felt a terrible pain
in the middle of the night.
We will ideally be required to view
this documentary at regular intervals,
especially after a bruising fight
with our partner.
It would provide crucial evidence,
which our own memories are
so good at strategically omitting
of how less than ideal
the single state can be
We would realise that
though we are sad now,
we were also very sad then.
We would accept, with good grace
and touch of dark humour,
that life simply gives us
few opportunities to be content.